la liberté ça n'est pas faire ce qu'on
veut c'est être responsable de ce que
l'on fait et donc la liberté sans la
responsabilité n'est et n'existent pas
et du coup ce qui est important de
comprendre c'est que si on ce qui s'est
passé en france est ce que j'ai vraiment
l'impression est ce qui me terrifie
vraiment c'est que on a délégué notre
responsabilité individuelle à l'état
c'est à dire que attend que l'état ne
nous l'interdît pas c'est que c'est pas
dangereux c'est on est vraiment dans une
approche où on a accepté non seulement
on a accepté mais on a réclamé une
certaine forme d'infantilisation et on
s'est complètement déresponsabiliser et
c'est ça qui entraîne un cercle vicieux
on ne peut pas tout faire au nom de la
santé
c'est peut-être choquant de dire ça mais
aussi si on devait tout faire au nom de
la santé oms bloquerait complètement le
pays on imposerait chat à chacun de se
limiter de ne pas sortir chez lui il y
aurait les militaires dans la rue et
pourtant le fais pas ça veut dire qu'il
ya quelque chose en face qui est encore
plus important que la santé qui est de
dire on doit respecter un certain nombre
de libertés individuelles et quand on
prend l'exemple de deux personnes très
âgées qu'on a envie de protéger
on a tous envie de protéger nos aînés
mais quand vous aînés ne sont pas sûrs
de 2,2 d'être là dans le sait peut-être
leur dernier noël dans la fin décembre
ils ont peut-être envie de voir leur
leurs petits enfants et leurs enfants
et ça on peut pas leur en vouloir de la
même manière que quelqu'un qui dit je
vais à la messe on peut je veux aller à
la messe on peut trouver ça on peut
trouver ça terrifiant de trouver ça
stupide on peut leur dire mais est ce
que on doit les empêcher d'y aller
moi je suis je pense qu'il ya une limite
à mettre entre je vous recommande je
pense que ce n'est pas une bonne chose
et je ne lui viendrait pas vous voir si
vous faites cette action et jeu et je me
tiens on va écarter de vous et et de
dire je vais mettre un policier en face
pour t'empêcher et faire ton bien à ta
place et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important cette ligne là je
pense que la suède a été beaucoup plus
prudente et je pense que c'est
extrêmement important qu'on n'oublie pas
ce que c'est que la liberté et que la
liberté c'est aussi la responsable
[Musique]